april 2021 getting ready to do this
finally how
um you know is it a release or how happy
are you to finally say okay we're going
to be able
for everybody to see this you know what
i think everything is pretty much like
this this
this kind of like it's like being on a
roller coaster
and you're just at the tip of it and
you're literally just like
crossing your fingers and hoping that
like that this will be the one to get us
all to come back
to the theaters you always say never
turn your back on family
but you turned your back on me
now your little family is in my world
i was like just when i thought i had
seen it all now we got flying cars and
cabinets and you need that dobie sound
baby
you know when you saw like even just
that part of it were you like yeah we
did the damn thing
we did you know what i mean
there is something to be said about fast
and furious being one of those movies
that belongs in a
movie theater my favorite it just hands
down it's it's the experience of it it's
the fact that you know
you three generations in you know the
people watched it in the 2000s with
their parents now they're bringing their
own kids
you know to the game to the mix and it's
a tradition it's true i mean i walked in
my neighborhood i walked past and i
smelled popcorn the other day and i
looked and i said
it's open i i i literally had my mouth
open like oh my god it's open
um let me ask you this because you
talked about you know people wanting to
come back to the theater
and hopefully we can get back in that
space this year marks 20 years for this
franchise michelle 2000 yeah
film you know isn't that crazy man it's
bananas
it's bananas how does it feel to be
celebrating two decades
with this film in particular you know
you owe me a 10-second car right
[Applause]
i mean it's surreal i feel like you know
i feel like i was such a baby back then
you know and and to see how much we've
grown you know now vin's got a whole
entire
family i'm you know the godmother to his
kids like it's
crazy it's like um it's a very beautiful
journey
and then to think that we could
represent something for people around
the world
is like a whole other monster it's like
we take it very seriously and and
hold it very dear to our hearts and and
treat it very preciously
yeah and you know one of the things i
think i that i love and i know so many
other
um fans of this franchise love is the
fact that
um you all still have been able to
celebrate the spirit of paul walker
throughout the rest of this franchise
and in this trailer we get to see
um that again just talk about you know
the need for that
and then also how you're celebrating him
in this film
as well the ninth one of the franchise
you know what
you know at the end of the day it's the
idea of
of of being able to bring back the
living you know
and so you know jordana brewster you
know she
she's a big part of the franchise she's
one of the og's of the original and
you know to lose her completely because
of the fact that you know that we lost
somebody dear to uh
we can't address that in the story and
so in the fast and furious
you know world he's still alive in our
hearts and so
that's how we're going to keep it for
now you know until we can answer that
very tough question you know story wise
i think that that it's the right thing
to do
is to keep him alive in in our hearts
and in the story
one of the other things i love about the
franchise is the fact that we get to see
fully realized females female characters
kicking butt being vulnerable doing all
the things and in the trailer i'm like
go michelle i was like literally
screaming were you hiding yeah what
about all the stuff you got to do
you know what at the end of the day i
was really more hyped about being able
to see
mia come back into the mix and get her
action sequences and have a new
character anna introduced
have natalie doing something other than
typing into a computer
you know what i mean i was just blown
away like the
the ability to like actually show them
and and and let them express themselves
like
i win oh yeah i win when they win i win
when all the girls win
so like the more the more air time you
get for the females in the franchise and
and the more love you show them the
happier i'll always be
like it's just makes me feel good inside
because it's been a long time coming you
know
yeah listen you can't be a female writer
damn it
and this show i think is in the right
hands justin back directed i think i
think it's
really really great um but let me ask
you real quick because you've got
dungeons and dragons coming up
as well you know what i'm gonna be a
barbarian
uh in this one and so you know i've just
been training
i've been lots of protein oh my god and
i'm hoping to gain the weight necessary
to just be able to carry an axe
appropriately
um so i'm in the mix with chris chris
pine i can't wait to work with him i've
always heard nothing but great things
about this guy
and we're about to be in ireland man you
know in the bubble because they're
putting us in a bubble
having those things shoved up our noses
three times a week you know for
insurance purposes make sure everybody's
safe
but man i am not looking forward to that
now i'm looking forward to making the
movie but i'm not looking forward to
being tested three times a week i mean
they're touching
with that thing yeah i've been doing it
since august oh so you know
it's not the greatest but michelle the
fact that we can get back to work and
you can make this movie you know what
i'm nothing but grateful i am nothing
but grateful i kiss the lucky stars
every day